Let's look at the answer for
our cache line size quiz.
We are asked to determine which of
these are not good line sizes for
a 2 kilobyte cache?
A 1 byte line is not a good one because
it doesn't exploit spatial locality and
because Word size accesses will
need to access multiple blocks or
multiple lines in the cache.
So this is definitely not a good size.
Thirty-two bytes is a good size.
It exploits spatial localities, it's not
too large, and it's a power of 2, so
we can easily locate blocks.
If I give you an address, you can easily
find what block does it belong to.
Forty-eight bytes is a good size,
as far as, it's not too large or
too small but it's not a power of 2.
So if we are given an address and
we need to find out what is the block
that contains that address,
we need to divide by 48,
which is much more complicated
then dividing by a power of 2.
For example, for a 32 byte size,
the lowest 5 bits of the address tell
us where we are within the block,
this kind of telling us where within
the 32 bytes of a block we are and
the upper bits of the address
basically are the block number.
We divide by 32, simply by
discarding the lowermost 32 bytes.
In contrast, dividing by 48 bytes would
actually need to be a division by 48.
So this is not a good line size.
Sixty-four bytes is also
a reasonable block size.
It's larger then 32 but still a lot
of them fit in a 2 kilobyte cache.
One kilobyte is good because
it's a power of 2 but
only two of them fit
in a 2 kilobyte cache.
So this is not a good line
size because it is too large
given that the cache is
only 2 kilobytes in size.
What we want to have as a block size is
something that is a power of 2, exploits
spatial locality but still a significant
number of them fit in our cache.